queremos determinar el valor del
siguiente límite el límite que cuando x
tiende a 1 b en la siguiente expresión
de la expresión x entre x menos uno
menos 1 entre el logaritmo natural de x
ahora pues vamos a ver qué pasa si
intentamos poner x igual a 1 en la
expresión qué pasa si evaluamos en 1
entonces obtenemos en to tenemos lo
siguiente un 1 aquí entre un 1 menos 1
algo del estilo 1 entre 0 - 1 entre cuál
es el logaritmo natural de 1 y a la que
me da 1 pues bueno cualquier cosa a la 0
me da 1 entonces a la 0 es 1 y por tanto
el logaritmo natural de 1 es cero
entonces vemos que tenemos esta forma
indeterminada del estilo 1 entre 0 - 1
entre 0 que se extraña porque no es de
la forma usual del hopital pero es una
expresión rara no es la forma normal del
estilo 0 entre 0 o de la forma infinito
entre infinito y entonces pues podemos
decir pues esto no parece ser algo que
sea del hospital entonces hay que
resolverlo de otra forma pero pues sabes
que no hay que rendirnos aún a lo mejor
esta cosa de la izquierda podemos
manipular la algebraica mente para que
tengamos una forma del estilo del
hospital y podamos aplicar la regla
entonces para hacer esto
pues vamos a ver qué pasa cuando sumamos
estas dos expresiones si las sumamos
pues hay que ver cuál es el denominador
común es x menos 1 por logaritmo natural
de x simplemente las multiplique y bueno
el numerador para el de el numerador
tenemos que ver qué pasa si
multiplicamos x entre x menos 1 por lo
acarició natural de x no nos queda x
logaritmo natural de x y después tenemos
que restar tenemos que restar un x menos
1 entonces menos x menos 1
podemos partirla en cachitos y ver que
estas dos expresiones son igualitas esto
de acá de la izquierda pues es lo mismo
que x entre x menos 1 porque el
logaritmo natural de x se cancela arriba
y abajo
y pues del otro lado del lado derecho
pues también es lo mismo que uno entre
logaritmo natural de x porque el x menos
1 de arriba y de abajo se cancela
entonces puesto al sumar estas dos cosas
debe pasar algo más interesante vamos a
tomar el límite cuando x tiende a 1 de
esta nueva expresión porque estas dos
son la misma cosa a lo mejor tenemos
algo más padre entonces tenemos uno por
el logaritmo natural de uno que es cero
esto es un cero
es un cero y luego hay que restar 11 que
es otro cero entonces nos queda el
numerador cero
y en el denominador tenemos un 11 que es
un 0 x un logaritmo natural de 1 que es
otro 0 que nos va a dar 0 y ahí está
encontramos una forma indeterminada de
tipo local una cosa del estilo 0 entre 0
entonces tenemos que derivar arriba
abajo y va a ver qué pasa entonces este
límite si acaso existe va a ser igual al
límite de cuando x tiende a 1 de y pues
hay que derivar vamos a ver qué pasa
vamos a derivar el numerador en magenta
y para esta primera parte hay que
utilizar la regla del producto la
derivada de x es 1 entonces uno por el
logaritmo natural de x después hay que
sumar pues la derivada del logaritmo
natural de x 1 entre x por el primer
término que es x la regla del producto
para derivadas entonces después hay que
derivar x menos 1 y hay que restar
la derivada de x1 es la derivada es 1
entonces hay que poner un -1 entonces
todo esto de acá tenemos que dividir lo
tenemos que dividirlo entre la derivada
de x menos uno logaritmo de x del
denominador entonces la derivada de x
menos uno es uno así que simplemente hay
que multiplicar eso por logaritmo
natural de x y después hay que sumar la
derivada del logaritmo natural del
segundo término que es 1 / x por x menos
1 es el primer término x menos 1 y pues
podemos simplificar un poco esta
expresión porque este uno entre x al
multiplicarse por x es un 1 que al
restarle el 1 se cancelan y entonces
toda esta expresión puede escribirse un
poco más simple como el límite de cuando
x tiende a 1 b el logaritmo natural de x
lo dejamos en 90 y dividimos entre el
logaritmo natural de x más x menos 1
entre x
vamos muy bien entonces vamos a intentar
evaluar esta cosa en x igual a 1 a ver
qué pasa entonces va a ser algo del
estilo bueno logaritmo de 1 es 0 estamos
dividiendo entre el logaritmo natural de
uno que es cero otra vez
y tenemos que sumar 1 - 1 entre entre un
1 o sea es 1 - 1 entre 1 que es otro 0
entonces cuando hacemos eso volvemos a
obtener un 0 entonces es una vez más una
forma del estilo 0 entre 0 esto nos dice
que tenemos que volver a usar la regla
del hopital entonces derivamos numerador
denominador y vamos a ver qué pasa
debería de ser igual al límite en el
límite de cuando x tiende a 1
de la derivada del logaritmo de x que es
una entre x
por qué es la derivada del logaritmo de
x y eso hay que dividirlo entre la
derivada del denominador la derivada del
logaritmo de x es uno entre x y luego
hay que sumar la derivada de x 1 entre x
entonces tenemos que ver aquí es más
fácil verlo la derivada de uno entre x
que x a la menos uno pues vamos a ver
qué pasa con esta éste es x al menos uno
y es simplemente menos x a la menos y
hay que multiplicarlo por el segundo
término x menos 1 aplicando la regla del
producto y hay que sumar la derivada de
el segundo término x menos uno por uno
entre x por 1 en 3
y entonces esto va a ser igual hay
disculpas ario algo raro en mi
computadora disculpa eso si lo
escuchaste bueno estábamos en en
simplificará claro
estábamos en usar la regla del hopital
esto va a ser igual a va a ser igual a y
aquí ya podemos evaluar para x igual a 1
en el numerador tenemos 1 entre 1 que es
1 y ya nos escapamos de las formas
indeterminadas o al menos de la cero
entre 0 y en el denominador si evaluamos
en 1 tenemos un 1 y hay que sumar menos
1 a la menos 2 o sea 1 a la menos 2 y
luego con menos se hace menos 1 pero por
el 1 menos 1 se hace un 0 todo es todo
esto se cancela y hay que sumar un 1
entre 1 que es otro 1 finalmente
llegamos a un medio y ahí está
terminamos el problema usamos la regla
del hopital unos cuantos pasos al
principio no parecía una cosa del estilo
0 entre 0 pero sumamos obtuvimos esta
expresión derivamos numerador y
denominador un par de veces
y obtuvimos nuestros resultados